yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing a river Boca okay I've lost one
against him how did I do that
aa-are okay it was a this opening I miss
played this ending
I remember that where overestimated my
chances and got duly punished yeah we
had to sweat this opening exactly this
Scotch for Knights
yeah Blake has a couple of setups mostly
they involve c6 it's not totally
necessary but oftentimes just quite
useful cover d5 and give more
flexibility to the pieces so they don't
need to protect e5 anymore but all in
all there are a couple of possibilities
that black can play for this is
something that is now possible which is
not possible of course without will c6
being played it's not a big deal but I
can try I try to see if I can provoke a
weakness here not sure the knight is
that great there to be honest now that I
look at this a little bit I wonder about
it anyway I can go here on C if I tape
on e6 I just fine
my interesting so before now we just
let's do this
I'm trying to keep his pawns fixed on
night squares
yeah it was pretty much expected I don't
think no thinking it could be five but
it doesn't do anything good mostly just
trades a five is a very useful standard
move to get rid of them and we gave on
okay so now I can take on it six if I
like it looks like it should win a pawn
somehow I mean
yeah I don't if he's got many things
hanging he 6c six and there are tactics
like with Ruger context I was through a
age where it's kind of overloaded okay
this is a simple move that I did not
take into account okay
I mean I can be better probably by
taking but probably yeah okay I mean I
probably shouldn't have taken only six
now looking at this position but I mean
it's not not a problem I'm not worse or
anything okay so okay one maybe if he
takes before I get both pawns so I'm not
really worried about it
king f7 would be a funny move to Kevin
Kelly six yeah okay now what to do
Queen c7 or is there anything better
than trying to try to go into the light
squares could be interesting that looks
very very normal
throughout the new book a7
I have Bishop f5 or Bishop g6 it's not
going to be so easy to defend I think
yeah we got seven this bishop g6 going
for counter check that's a good move
sorry
I mean I can still take it right Queen
d7 queen of two King H to check em Eve
for Kim
so still a little bit annoying all this
so how do you cover g7 yeah this problem
okay okay
f11 yeah let's do it
I mean he has to always cover g7 sure eg
the only has this one check
[Music]
it's made on G to Jesus I did not see it
at all
shoot they have no move or the game
what is silly game a queen e6 queen g4
so wins yeah sorry I didn't see it I
mean that is totally sick I need more
time and everything yeah if you lose
games like that you should really switch
to some other sport him I mean it was
like a one-sided can you be here anyway
yeah so here White has very nice control
and after this I'm just clearly better
actually okay let's not criticize too
much of my opponents playing get get
those messages again that I after lose
and keep criticizing blacks play on my
opponent's flag let me just is just
atrocious you just don't play Queen b7
and allow the capture on e6 because your
structure is a complete wreck after it
and it just what happened I mean I am
anyway so here I had something better
okay five or taking yeah okay it's so
pretty annoying for him but he can take
Queen f6 that is ellison that's the
resource that i definitely should not
have allowed no no no he I've got
nothing so that means that I have to
here have to really be more precise look
85 is an interesting move trying to
double on the air farm and
basically claiming that the a pawn is
too strong which is probably true
the a porn supported by the bishop will
be very strong yeah in the game he
played this which is just giving me a
piece and then I don't win which is
really really great yeah did I didn't
have anything substantially better up to
this point
rook G 1 is of course strong I am when
you see it it's easy this is giving him
giving him a bit too much counter play
Queen e6 rook f7 still wins which I mean
even the final position is of course a
complete win but I didn't see it I was
so shocked that there was the maid
threat yeah this is stuff fairly easy I
was so shocked about the maid threat
that I didn't see the defense okay
thanks for watching